hey guys uh I don't know how Joe Biden
did this but there are more people
working in the United States today than
at any previous time in the history of
the country if you can believe that
Obama now
this is of course Very tongue-in-cheek
but it is also true if you're new to
this show
I I really want you to pay special
attention to this segment because this
is actually I I really want to do this
the right way okay we started seeing
headlines late last week like this one
record number of Americans employed in
December
159 million 244
000 record number of Americans employed
in December now this is one of my
favorite political footballs depending
on whether you want to argue the economy
is good or the economy is bad for
politically partisan reasons you can
very often use phrases like there are
more Americans than ever currently
working or there are more Americans than
ever currently not working or you can go
away from the number and talk about the
percentage you can say the labor
participation rate is higher than ever
or the rate is lower than ever okay this
is all basically BS in a vacuum so let's
really break down what's going on here
in the United States the population
continues to increase and so if over
time there's an average labor
participation rate let's just call it 60
okay one of the things that will be true
is that the number of people working and
the number of people not working will
both be at record highs think through
the numbers it's very simple in a
country of a hundred million people with
a 60 labor participation rate you would
have 60 million people working and 40
million people not working great
time goes by you get to 200 million
people in the population that 60 labor
participation right now means wow we
have 120 million people working we have
a record number of people working but we
also have 80 million people not working
we have a record number of people not
working is the economy good or is the
economy bad I don't know depends who who
what what point you want to make or what
you want to justify so it's not actually
a great indicator of how the economy is
doing but what's ironic what's funny
what's interesting is that Republicans
love to take either the number of people
working
or the labor participation rate out of
context to make the case that the
economy is good or bad now let me show
you a couple of different things here
this is a chart of the labor
participation rate as you can see this
goes back before 1950. I'll describe it
to you it's not as high as it's ever
been right now the labor participation
rate is between 62 and 63 percent in the
late 90s early 2000s the labor
participation rate was 67 so right now
if you are one of the politically
partisan people that wants to say the
economy is bad you go we are a full Five
Points lower in terms of the labor
participation rate than we were 20 years
ago it's terrible right now okay that's
one perspective however if instead of
looking at the rate we look at the
number of people working which is what
that that headline I showed you says you
would accurately be able to say
there are more people than ever working
right now
that being said
you would also have to figure out if
there are more people than ever not
working right now because of the growth
of the population so let me be very real
with you okay
in order to figure out how the economy
is doing you have to look at many
factors and you should be looking at the
employment rate you should be looking at
job creation it's useful to look at
stock market performance to a degree
consumer confidence look at inflation
look at wages look at export import
balance at trade bound there's a bunch
of different things that we would look
at one of the problems with the labor
participation rate or the number of
people working is how it is composed so
a lot of times right-wingers love to say
the unemployment rate isn't accurate
because if you stop looking for work you
no longer count as unemployed that's
true but that's always been the case
that was the case when Reagan was
President and those very same
Republicans talked about how great the
unemployment rate was that's always the
case that's a limitation of the of the
measurement the problem with the labor
participation rate is sometimes when
people aren't working it's because the
economy is good I'm going to give you
some examples okay if you are a High
School junior or senior or in college
meaning you're like between 16 and 22
years old okay if you're in College
full-time in these numbers you show up
as someone who's not working you show up
as you're you're in the not working part
but the reason you might be able to
afford to go to College full-time is
because the economy is good and your
parents work and they don't need you to
work to help feed the family
you could also look at the inverse you
could have a higher labor participation
because all of these people who could be
in college have to work because the
economy is so bad their household with
their parents needs more income
I'll give you another example
stay-at-home parents lower
the labor participation rate but if the
economy were really bad a lot of those
stay-at-home parents would have to go
out and get a job so stay-at-home
parents make this number look worse but
it's a sign that the economy is better
I'll give you another example when
people retire they exit the labor force
they show up on that not working side if
the economy is good more people can
afford to retire if the economy is bad
more of those people who would like to
retire can't they keep working you've
got a higher labor participation but not
because the economy is good because it's
bad so you get the picture it's a very
deceptive number by itself Republicans
love using it what's the truth of the
matter the truth of the matter is the
economy is pretty good right now the
stock market is sort of stabilizing
inflation's coming down job creation
numbers are better than expected
um unemployment's low is it a perfect
economy of course not is there suffering
is there poverty is there hunger of
course there's all of those things but
by the metrics we normally use the
economy is doing pretty well now one one
last thing on this Joe Biden's approval
rating does seem to be responding to a
lot of different things but it's
basically been an increasing approval
rating since late July for Joe Biden so
late July Biden's approval bottomed out
it then spiked by early September and
it's been just like a slow burn increase
to close to 44 is 44 an amazing approval
rating no in the modern era of hyper
partisanship is it a typical approval
rating for a president who's doing the
job well enough yeah it's sad that our
standards are that low but it is it's uh
certainly no disaster and it will be
interesting to see how that impacts the
coming to year so more people than ever
working is it the be-all end-all of
judging the economy it is not but I hope
you all give me credit I don't play the
partisan games with the labor force
participation rate
one of our sponsors today is blue chew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping